قل مرحبًا بالشتاء ،
ليس فقط أي حيوان لاما ، قد ينقذنا دمها
جميعًا من covet 19 ،
اكتشف الباحثون أن اللاما تنتج نوعًا من
الأجسام المضادة التي يمكن أن تكون حيوية في مكافحة
عدوى فيروس كورونا لدى البشر.
وأكثر
استقرارًا ، جاءت لحظة eureka في هذا
المختبر البلجيكي الصغير في 20 كانون الثاني (يناير) ، حيث
أدركوا أن البحث عن اللاما
قبل عامين يمكن أن يدفعهم إلى
العلاج سريعًا وتوسيع نطاقه على الفور من
2 إلى 20 موظفًا ، لذلك عملنا
حقًا لساعات طويلة  وخاصة في
فبراير ومارس وعندما كنا
نتسابق للحصول على الجسم المضاد الآن ، فإنهم
يتسابقون الآن لاختبار أجسامهم المضادة على
الفئران والهامستر ، كل شيء
يحدث هنا بسرعة أكبر بكثير من
المعتاد ، ولكن لا يزال الأمر يستغرق وقتًا حتى
يحتوي الفلاش الأبيض هناك على مليارات من
الأجسام المضادة التي يمكن استخدامها في حوالي
مائة اختبار على الحيوانات ولكن حتى ذلك يمكن أن
يستغرق ما يصل إلى عشرة أيام لإنتاجها بشكل غير عادي
لمختبر أكاديمي بهذا الحجم الصغير.
تنظيم مسارات متوازية لتكرير
الأجسام المضادة أثناء التخطيط
لاختيار الأفضل وتوسيع نطاقها للبشر
بمجرد أن يضطروا إلى إجراء دراسات ترتيب متعددة
مثل السمية ، كرر بعض
التجارب على الحيوانات ، ومن ثم نأمل بحلول
نهاية العام أن يكون كل شيء في
مكان لإجراء الاختبارات السريرية الأولى ،
يمكن أن يكون أكبر المستفيدين من
كبار السن لأن أجهزتهم
المناعية أضعف بشكل عام يمكن أن تساعد الأجسام المضادة في المختبرات
في فعالية اللقاحات
التي تم اختبارها بالفعل ، لذا قد
يكون اللقاح قد يحمي البالغين الأصحاء
ولكن قد يكون أقل فائدة في  كبار
السن وبهذه الطريقة فقط من خلال توفير
الجسم المضاد نفسه بشكل مباشر ، قد
تحمي كبار السن أيضًا ولكن العديد من
الأشخاص نفد صبرهم ومزرعة المنبه في المملكة المتحدة ،
بوبي شوك ، بدأت تشعر بالبرد بالفعل
بشأن إمكانيات الشفاء من
اللاما التي كان لدينا أشخاص سخيفون
في بلدي.  الرأي الذي اتصل هاتفيا وسأل
هل يمكنهم القدوم وأخذ الدم من
اللاما لشربه ولكن لا ، لن
نذهب  الأشخاص الذين يشربون دمائهم وإذا
فعلوا ذلك ، فلن يساعد
ذلك في عدم عمل الأجسام المضادة ، ما
يقلق الباحثين في بلجيكا هو
أن الوقت قد ينفد
حيث تبدأ عمليات الإغلاق في التراجع إذا نظرت
إلى أرقام الحالات اليومية على مستوى العالم
فهي ثابتة.  إنه فقط لدينا حوالي
مائة ألف حالة كل يوم في جميع
أنحاء العالم للشهر الماضي ، نعم من
الواضح تمامًا أنه بمجرد أن نهدأ
الأمور مع السفر الدولي ،
ستعود ، ولذا فنحن بحاجة إلى أن نكون
مستعدين لذلك الشتاء في  من ناحية أخرى ،
يمكن أن تأخذ الأمر سهلاً في
وظيفتها بإعطاء رمز الجسم المضاد الخاص بها تم
إنجاز
المستشفيات وظائف فقد الأشخاص في
الأقنعة في كل مكان تنظر فيه هناك
علامات على أزمة الفيروس التاجي إنها
مجرد البداية حتى نحصل على
لقاح فعال وما لم
يحدث شيء غير متوقع للغاية
عدونا الفيروسي  سيبقى معنا لعدة
أشهر وربما سنوات عديدة
يتسابق الباحثون لإيجاد لقاح
يمنع كوفين 19:00 وفقًا
لعالم منظمة الصحة العالمية
لدينا أكثر من مائة لقاح قيد التطوير في جميع أنحاء العالم مع اعتماد ثمانية على الأقل للتجارب السريرية ، وعادة ما يستغرق الأمر ثلاثة أو أربعة أشهر لإثبات أن اللقاح آمن ، وهذا في الواقع هو السؤال الأول الأكثر أهمية ، ومن ثم نريد معرفة ما إذا كان يمكن تحمله حسنًا ، وإذا كانت تنتج استجابة للأجسام المضادة التي قد تكون وقائية ، لكن الخبراء يقولون إننا على الأرجح لن نعرف ما إذا كانت هذه اللقاحات تعمل حتى العام المقبل نتحدث عن جدول زمني تعرفه لمدة عام هنا أو ربما أفضل قليلاً ، فنحن محظوظون جدًا ، اشتعلت النيران في عملية تطوير اللقاح بينما ينتظر العالم ستبدو الحياة مختلفة في مدرسة Three Forks Montana عادت إلى الجلسة التي كنت أثق بها على مدار السنوات العديدة الماضية لرعاية أطفالي وأنا أثق بهم الآن ارتدى المعلمون أقنعة و الطلاب بعيدون اجتماعيًا أثناء دخولهم مدرسة Willow Creek لأول مرة منذ أن بدأ جائحة فيروس كورونا ، يعلمون أنهم لا يستطيعون معانقة أصدقائهم الذين يعرفونهم  تجلسوا بعيدًا عنه
لكنهم سعداء بالعودة ،
إحدى الطرق التي يحمينا بها جهاز المناعة
لدينا من الفيروسات هي من خلال
الأجسام المضادة ، والأجسام المضادة هي بروتينات في
دمائنا تلتصق
بأجزاء من الفيروسات تحد من
العدوى وتنبه أيضًا الدم الأبيض
تدخل الخلايا في الهجوم والقضاء
على الفيروس ، لذلك في كثير من الحالات إذا
واجه الجسم نفس الفيروس مرة أخرى ، يكون لدى
الجهاز المناعي بقايا الأجسام المضادة
التي يتم تعليمها وتذكر
العدوى السابقة ، يمكن لهذه الخلايا
إما محاربة الفيروس القاتل
مباشرة أو يمكنها إنتاج المزيد
الأجسام المضادة للمساعدة في منع العدوى
ليس الباحثون متأكدين تمامًا من سبب
نجاح هذه العملية مع بعض
الفيروسات ولكن ليس البعض الآخر يبدو أن جهاز المناعة لدينا
يتذكر بعض الفيروسات بشكل أفضل
من الآخرين ، حيث
يكون الشخص محميًا بشكل عام مدى الحياة
بعد مواجهة واحدة مع فيروسات مثل
جدري الماء أو  لكن هناك
بعض الفيروسات التي يبدو أن أجهزتنا المناعية
تنسى بسهولة أن العلماء قد
أبلغوا عن ذلك المناعي  يمكن أن تكون
فترة قصيرة
بعد مواجهة بعض
فيروسات كورونا الموسمية الشائعة التي يمكن أن
تسبب نزلات البرد التي يمكن أن تساعد في تفسير
سبب مرضنا بشكل متكرر
بشيء بسيط مثل الزكام حتى لو
اعتقدنا أننا تعرضنا لفيروسات البرد من
قبل  يمكن أن نتعرض
لسلالات جديدة أيضًا
ويمكن أن تتغير بعض الفيروسات مثل الإنفلونزا في كثير من الأحيان مما
يعني أن أجسامنا المضادة القديمة لم تعد تعمل
ضد السلالات الجديدة بينما
يعتقد معظم الخبراء أننا على الأرجح سنحصل
على بعض الحماية بعد
الإصابة بـ  فيروس كورونا ما
زلنا غير متأكدين من المدة التي
ستستغرقها هذه الحماية أو مدى قوتك